[Music]
[Applause]
hey hey we know each other your friend
from work everybody thought you were
dead so much has happened since I last
saw you lost my hammer like yesterday so
still pretty fresh Loki Loki Loki's
alive can you believe it he's like he's
up there so much has happened since I
last saw you
I lost my hammer like yesterday so
that's still pretty fresh but then I
went on a journey of self-discovery
I love you
[Music]
Wow you have no idea how long ago does
the death hasn't faded as God oh I've
missed this
and you and I had a fight with me today
where
now I want easily this in sound right
well that's true
as God is dead and it will be reborn in
my image I thought you'd be glad to see
me
neither stopper here now to prevent
Ragnarok the end of everything
so I'm putting together a team
like the old days
surprise this is such fun
he's a fighter
I'm not a queen or a monster
I'm the goddess of death
what were you the god of again
we're the same you and I just a couple
of hotheaded fools yeah same old like
fire door like water mama kind of puffs
like fire butthole like raging fire so I
like smoldering fire
[Music]